everyone Wow I'm excited to be here and
I'm really really excited that we get to
start this day off and the conference
actually talking about peer-to-peer
protocols because something I think is
super fascinating and I have some
interesting stuff to show off later in
my talk this talk is called reclaiming
the web with peer-to-peer protocols but
before I dive in and tell you what in
the world that's all about I want to
introduce myself
hi I'm Tara van sole and I'm a web
developer I'm also really really into
anything to do with nails and nail art
and I love music especially if it's from
Beyonce so if you like nails or Beyonce
or both we should definitely talk later
on I'm a web developer but I've spent
about the last year and a half in a kind
of a strange role because instead of
working on a team where my job is to
build websites
I've actually been building a browser
with these two guys P Frazee and Maffin
Tosh and we've been building a browser
because we had some weird experiments
that we wanted to run and we figured
that the browser was the best place to
do that and the browser we're building
is called beaker and it's an
experimental browser which means that
we're doing experiments in the like the
science way it doesn't mean that it's
like buggy or you know just like a
really basic prototype it actually works
you can download it and the core
experiment we're running in beaker is
what happens when you put a peer-to-peer
protocol into the browser some pretty
interesting things happen it turns out
like being able to publish a website
from the browser and being able to offer
experimental peer-to-peer api's to
developers I'm gonna tell you a lot more
about beaker and in fact I'm going to
show you beaker later and before I do
that I want to spend some time to
reflect on what even is the web because
I think it's relevant to our
conversation so if I'm asking this to
reclaim the web I think we should
probably talk about who who took it in
the first place and what have they done
with the web right like I mean we're
we're all
here in this room at a conference
dedicated to the web so surely the web
can't be in too much trouble right I
actually have to agree I'm extremely
optimistic about the future of the web
and I'm really pleased with where the
web is at right now I'm really happy to
see so many new people still coming
coming to the web every day to learn how
to build things with HTML and JavaScript
and CSS and I'm pleased to see that the
tools that we depend on like NPM web
pack Babel are steadily improving to
make our workflows seamless in our lives
easier and I'm thrilled to see that
browsers are working really hard to
improve the feature set of the web and
improve compatibility across browsers
and if you're not optimistic about the
web for some reason I might highlight
that earlier this week the chrome
developer summit happened and this was
an opportunity for the chrome developers
and the chrome team to share their ideas
and their prototypes about how the web
is going to move forward they announced
some really cool proposals like virtual
scrolling which should hopefully improve
loading as you scroll down a page and
some other neat stuff was demoed like
Houdini which is an improvement on how
CSS works and seeing all these really
neat announcements earlier this week it
gave me some time to reflect on some of
the wins that the web has had recently
like CSS grid which if I dare say makes
composing layouts like actually kind of
fun or or the fact that boku has been
working really hard with the w3c and
other browser vendors to build a huge
test suite for compatibility across the
web the web is making progress and I
think it's really important to recognize
that and especially to recognize the
people that make it happen because their
jobs are not easy and also because the
web is a miracle of human cooperation
when you think about it will you take a
second to think about what the web is
even is it's a miracle that it exists
and let alone that it's improving the
web is this strange thing where seven
billion people on earth have somehow
come together and decided on a language
for how we build digital stuff and get
it from one computer to another like
that is absolutely absolutely miraculous
that we pulled that off and the end
result is it doesn't look that exciting
but it's actually really cool right you
have a web page and no matter what
context you're browsing it in with
there's some you have a reasonable
expectation that it will work
consistently and if you'll allow me a
moment to be sentimental I just want to
say that I think that's badass this is a
talk about reclaiming the web though so
even though I am really optimistic about
the web I'm a little bit worried too I'm
worried because the web isn't perfect
and honestly that's okay especially when
you think about how the web is this
weird amorphous set of technologies that
we have all just agreed to use but
that's pretty much the only thing that
binds it together is our shared
agreement to use it and on top of that
the web is only 28 years old the first
web browser was built in 1990 by Tim
berners-lee was called world wide web
app and it was only 25 years ago that
the first mainstream browser was
released that was called mosaic so we're
talking like we're operating on a really
small time scale here the web is a baby
so you can expect it to have some
problems the web is imperfect we can
accept that but I think the next step is
to then ask ourselves how are we going
to shape the next 30 years and by we I
mean actually we us the people in this
room who are web developers people who
may be influenced standards we do have
some say over how the web works mmm we
know that the web is gonna change right
because there are standards bodies and
browser vendors and other interested
parties who want to shape the web but
the question is of what values are we
going to choose to uphold in the next
thirty years what new features are we
going to enable how do we decide those
things I think oftentimes those things
are decided by our personal experiences
maybe someone in this room is a WebGL
developer so you might care a lot about
how graphics rendering will change on
the web in the next 30 years some of you
probably work with e-commerce and so you
might be paying more attention to the
web payments API or maybe some of you in
this room have been the target of a
focused harassment campaign on social
media and so you might have an interest
in seeing how the web learns from what
we've seen about how humans engage
online in the last 28 years the web is
very very new and we're still learning
so much about how communities work
online and how humans behave and when I
think about what I want the web to look
like in 30 years
honestly the community bit of it is what
interests me most yeah the graphics and
all the cool technical stuff about the
web is amazing it's what makes the web
the web but we come to the web because
we want to talk to people right we want
to share our interests we want to make
friendships and form communities so I'm
extremely interested to ask how can we
how can the web platform itself change
however subtly the ways that we interact
with each other online um whether you
like it or not right now this guy has a
lot of say over how online communities
work and I'm not sure he knew what he
was getting into when he started
Facebook but the point is that Facebook
is a massive global online community and
we've learned some kind of terrifying
things about humans interacting with
each other online
we're mean we're nasty we were reactive
we're just not very good at talking to
each other are we and this guy and
Sheryl Sandberg and some other folks are
in charge of movie helping us move
forward and I frankly don't think
they've stepped up to that
responsibility very well so I want us as
web developers and as a web community to
think about what can we do to adjust how
people talk to each other online is
there are there some knobs that we can
turn in terms of the technical
architecture of the web that can improve
the situation I don't know but this
question is what motivated to me
motivated me to work on Beeker
and it's been the guiding star in my
exploration and the experiments that
we've been running in beaker so to go
back to the question I mentioned earlier
what happens when you put a peer-to-peer
protocol in the browser would that be
the right knob to turn to maybe make it
a little bit nicer to communicate with
people online I don't know but I can
show you some of the experiments that
we've done and share some of the things
that we've learned in the process but
before I do that let's just take a look
at HTTP because this is the knob that we
turn in beaker the protocol knob this is
the most basic distillation of how HTTP
works right it's a client-server model
where one one person can upload data to
a server a server that belongs to let's
say Facebook Twitter whatsapp and a
person who wants to retrieve that data
it gets it from that service now there's
nothing inherently wrong with that
architecture but I would like to propose
that HTTP and this kind of client-server
architecture is a big part of why we've
gotten the way a big big part of why
online communities massive online
communities have turned out to be so
problematic in contrast this is what a
web based on a peer-to-peer protocol
looks like again this is a this is a
contrived example but it's a network
where in one individual can connect
directly to another individual and in
this case we're looking at someone
sending a message but we can also think
of web sites being transmitted from
computer to computer and cutting out
servers so why don't I just show you
because I think it's a lot more exciting
to see this stuff in action okay how's
that okay so this is beaker it's a
browser it's not terribly exciting to
look at when you're just looking at the
start page but it works like you would
expect a browser to work you can browse
HTTP web sites
so this is the beaker website again
nothing remarkable here but if you can
see in the very top right corner there's
this little tab that says p2p version
available it's really tiny but I promise
it's there and when I click that what's
gonna happen is it's going to take me to
the peer-to-peer version of this website
boom there it is you probably didn't
even see that um the only thing that's
different is the protocol it says dat
dat and that's just the protocol we use
in beaker and again this website doesn't
look like anything special it's just a
bunch of files CSS HTML images links
everything it works just the way you
would expect a browser to work okay so I
mentioned earlier that by putting a PDP
protocol in the browser we enabled some
things like being able to publish a
website from the browser so I'm gonna
show that off I'm gonna go to this top
right menu and click create new and I'm
gonna create a website using a basic
template that beaker provides and what's
gonna happen when I click this button is
beaker will literally create a new URL
for me and populate the website with
some basic template includes gonna
happen really fast and boom what we're
looking at here is beakers view source
tool I'll show you more of it later but
for now let me just set this title of
the website okay and then I'm gonna open
it up and here it is it's just a website
it doesn't really do anything except let
you change the background color but
what's really interesting about this is
this is a website and I could share the
URL with any of you you could open it up
in beaker and you could download the
website and all of its files directly
from me I didn't publish these files on
a server anywhere I did it all inside of
the browser so how do you edit websites
well if we jump back to our view source
tool we can actually look at all of the
files that compose a website so why
don't we open up the index.html and
let's actually edit it
I'm gonna change this to say hello
Seattle hits save button and when i
refresh you'll see the change cool I
want to also show off this neat feature
we have which is live reloading we went
ahead and put that right into the
browser just because it's so convenient
um
but if like all of us in this room or a
lot of us are developers we probably
have a preference about how we write
code we might like sublime or vs code
and you can totally do that with beaker
as well I just have to set a folder real
quick this is basically going to sync
the files over to a directory on my
computer I'm gonna turn off preview mode
okay so I'm going to open this up and
sublime so I'm gonna open the index.html
in sublime and we're going to go back to
this website we've got live reloading on
and I'm gonna edit the h1 tag again to
say hello from sublime and when I hit
save which I'm gonna do in three two one
you'll see the updates boom there we go
so this is neat but I I mentioned
earlier that beaker also has
peer-to-peer api's and this is really
where it gets exciting because static
websites are cool they make up a lot of
the web but they're not every part of
the web we still need applications where
people can have profiles and data of
related to their profiles and beakers
api's are the key to making that
possible so I'm going to open dev tools
and I'm going to show you a little bit
how this works okay to start off we need
to get access to the files that compose
this website so I'm going to do that
using beakers Det archive constructor
which basically just gives you some
which basically just gives you access to
the functions that help you connect to
the peer-to-peer network okay so we have
we have a variable that we're gonna be
able to work with here let's start off
with just listing all the files that are
in this website you might notice that
list this looks a lot like the node
filesystem API and that was on purpose
so let's do files dot read dear and
we're gonna read the top-level directory
and then we're going to console dot log
that's not right
console dot log the output okay what
we're seeing here is a listing of all
the files that compose this website
there's only six of them right now
okay let's see if we can read an
individual file the content Ella file
we'll do files dot read file let's do
the index.html okay there we're looking
at the actual content of this page so we
can we can do all sorts of things like
read files read file listings but we can
also write to files and this is gets
really interesting when you start
thinking about storing data and websites
so what I'm going to do is I'm actually
going to I'm actually going to overwrite
the HTML file for this website so we'll
say files dot write file and I'm going
to replace it with new h1 tag okay and
now when i refresh it's a totally new
index at HTML okay again this is sort of
a contrived example but I want to I want
to take it back to a real-world example
I said I'm really interested in thinking
about how online communities can be
shaped by that technology that underpins
them so I want to show you an
application that we built called fritter
okay so this is fritter and as you can
probably guess by the name and also the
appearance
is inspired by Twitter that was on
purpose I really like Twitter I like a
lot of things about Twitter I just like
some things about Twitter but I like
that it gives me a nice feed I can
follow my friends on and it like that
the content is short sweet and enjoyable
most of the time so we said what how far
can we get with building something like
Twitter using peer-to-peer protocols we
got pretty far actually it's it's pretty
cool so this doesn't look like much but
I'm gonna break down the architecture a
little bit so you can see how neat this
is ferner works in two pieces
there is the application itself which is
what we're looking at it's a JavaScript
application that uses beakers api's to
consume a profile and fetch data from
the peer-to-peer network and render it
into a nice feed and when I write a post
beaker uses the write file API to write
a post to my profile you know works like
you would expect but what does a profile
actually look like what is a profile
well it's not a row in a database that
lives up in a server somewhere it's just
a website and this is it it has some
metadata my name my bio well not my bio
it's my fake Beyonce profile so has the
information about the people I follow
and it contains my posts in JSON now
this is really really interesting
because we've separated the data from
the application which that's not news
we're used to doing that sort of thing
as developers but what is different is
that your profile on fritter is just a
website it's not tied to fritter if you
wanted to customize your own version of
fritter you could do that and your
application or your profile would still
work you wouldn't need to give up your
circle of friends or your content you
could just keep carry on carrying on
like normal and I think this
demonstrates a lot of potential for
building meaningful applications with
peer-to-peer protocols
fritter works this is my this is my demo
profile but there are posts from my
friends my like two friends and people
talk to each other I'm not going to say
that this is the ideal architecture for
moving forward on the peer-to-peer web
or that it won't have its own kind of
problems but it's a community kind of
controlled it's a kind of community
controlled social media and that's
really really excited to me because if
there's anything I've learned about
being a woman online in the last year
and a half is that sometimes you really
do want to take control over who you
talk to and who you don't talk to
because otherwise it gets a little bit
noisy so that is a quick and dirty tour
of beaker we're we're experimenting
we're doing a lot of things that are
strange and they most certainly do not
adhere to web standards but we're doing
it because we think it's worthwhile to
be a little bit messy and to just see
what happens we don't have the you know
the kind of reputation and like Apple or
Mozilla or Google does to to influence
standards bodies we're just some random
people that had an idea and we built it
so we hope that you'll find it
interesting and if you want to try out
beaker and see what other people have
built I recommend checking out my
website I have the p2p subdomain on my
website download beaker visit this URL
and I've got a huge collection of
websites jeans apps games and other
things that people have built on the
peer-to-peer web thank you so much for
coming to hear about beaker and the
peer-to-peer web if you have any
questions please do talk to me later and
you can check out the slides on my
website terra van socom slash slides
thank you so much